bonjour mathieu racer l'appareil je vous
appelle parce que j'ai reçu une lettre
de votre part vous voulez déjà est sûre
que vous ayez lu mon manuscrit
c'est un petit peu brusque comme réponse
peut pas juste dire voilà c'est ça nous
intéresse pas la famille doit récupérer
quelle famille belle famille samedi aux
soldats du marché
y en avoir les retours presse critique
est dithyrambique
merci beaucoup merci à vous une réussite
magistrale
c'est puissant au delà de tout ce que
vous pouvez imaginer
bonjour ma chérie je mathieu ça va faire
trois ans mathieu mais on n'a toujours
rien les gens commencent à se poser des
questions tu sais il faut juste que je
retravaille certains passages c'est tout
là j'ai bientôt fini il y avait une
lettre pour vous ce matin
à l'eau et à la mémoire
se présente ce qualifier de paf a rejeté
par les métiers vous tout cas tu peux
être fier d'avoir dompté notre avis
c'est pas la portée du premier venu je
ne couche pas pour vous vous êtes qui
bordel mes doigts mathieu tu sais que tu
es ses coûts c'est l'appel que tu reçois
te mentir alors ça avance dont roman
avec le deuxième c'est toujours le plus
dur tu dois avoir la pression
salez les femmes finissent toujours pas
savoir qui on est vraiment
n'appelez pas ici c'est clair
juste mais c'est tout